hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga although lately I do have to
admit that it seems to be mostly your
source for various things on to hunter
that's what the overwhelming majority of
you want so that's what you're going to
get and today we're back to modern
events specifically to discuss one of
the most anticipated battles in series
between Hisoka and crawler although I do
feel like battle is the wrong way to
describe this conflict because there was
a lot more to it than simple fighting
and honestly it was kind of akin to a
chess match but both competitors were
frequently heavily engaged in mental
calculations to come on top more so than
primal instinct and it really is a
masterclass in crafting a brilliant
sequence and deserves to be discussed
because there is an awful lot to dissect
here especially with crawlers insane
combination of borrowed and or stolen
abilities first up though just a little
background on what makes this a series
defining event in that it is important
to note that this is one of he sokka's
greatest desires brought to life
essentially everything this man has done
in the series was in service of fighting
strong opponents and the large majority
of those actions were specifically to
engage in combat with Crowe Lowe in
particular so this is something of a wet
dream to Hisoka in fact when I was first
reading it I wouldn't have been
surprised if immediately after its
conclusion
Hisoka suddenly woke up having made you
know a bit of a mess of his sheets but
whatever the case Crowley decided to
indulge hisoka's desires and the mad
magician was becoming nothing short of a
pain and as such the two agreed that
this would be a fight to the death now
there is a lot more to Chronos
contextual situation than this as he had
spent a great deal of time preparing for
this conflict and acquiring an ultimate
combination of abilities in order to
take he soaked it down and this is made
possible through crawlers hot suit
bandits secret a specialist ability that
allows him to steal the nen abilities of
others provided for very difficult
conditions are met which we won't go
into here but just be aware that krola
was something of an ability collector
and to this fight he brought a total of
six new powers into the mix the
combination of which he believed would
secure his victory the first ability of
which is a crawler original known as
double-faced now traditionally to invoke
a stolen power through bandits secret
Rollo needed to open his book to the
page in which the ability was listed in
order to gain access to its power
however would double-faced Rollo is able
to create a bookmark which when placed
on a page will allow crowler to continue
to use that ability even if the book is
closed or open but on another page and
this was very very relevant because
now allow krola to engage in
hand-to-hand combat while using an
ability due to no longer needing to keep
the book open at all times and much more
dangerously it allowed krola to access
to stolen skills and use them in concert
so you know it's probably history's most
powerful bookmark
next up crawler also acquired two
abilities from his very own members of
the Phantom troupe one of which is black
voice provided by shall knock this is a
stock standard manipulation ability that
allows it to use it to control the minds
and actions of a target by inserting an
antenna into them and providing them
with orders then we also have gallery
fake inability owned by koto P which
gives the user the power to touch an
object with their left hand and
replicate it with their right hand these
objects remain in existence for 24 hours
before disappearing however the user is
also able to track the movements of said
objects for the duration of that time
also very importantly gallery fake
cannot be used to replicate living
things or I mean it can sort of but if a
copy is made of a living thing then that
copy will come into existence as a
corpse during his prep time though a
crawler stole our further 3 abilities
from primarily unknown users one of
which was order stamp this power is a
combination of conjuration and
manipulation in which its user generates
a physical stamp and when a puppet is
marked with the stamp it allows the user
to control them although it does come
with a limitation that to be considered
a puppet the object must be both
lifeless and have a head quite notably
due to the beliefs of order stamps
original user corpses are not considered
puppets
however crawler would prove to
creatively circumvent that restriction
before we hop into that too much so
crawler also comes into this fight
wielding the Sun and the moon I mean not
the literal Sun and Moon but a very
funky hot sue which marks its uses hands
with a Sun symbol on one and a moon on
the other and whenever they use a touch
of someone or something with their hands
they will be marked with either the Sun
or the moon symbol respectively and
depending on how long this contact lasts
the symbols will be charged to a certain
extent with three to five seconds
required for maximum effect
now why is charging important well it's
because whenever a Sun and Moon symbol
come into contact with each other it
triggers an explosion the potency of
which is dependent on how charged the
symbols were upon contact rather
interestingly Sun and Moon is also a
case of post mortem known as its
original wielder an elder from eto City
as indeed passed away which would
usually remove the ability from crawlers
use however in this case his name became
more powerful after death allowing
crawler not only to retain the use of
this power but sun and moon also goes on
to circumvent the restrictions of
bandits
and double-faced keeping the symbols
active even if the ability is not
bookmarked or has its page open and the
only way to remove them is to trigger an
explosion and finally for this ability
dump we have convert hands which like
Sun and Moon produced marks on Crowley's
hands although in this case it is his
palms and this is quite a cool power as
when Crowley touches someone with his
right hand it will result in them taking
on Crowley's appearance whilst if he
touches someone with the left hand then
he will take on their likeness and of
course touching someone with both hands
pretty much means that their appearances
will be swapped so it's a very fine
ability for stealth and sowing confusion
amongst a crowd although it must be said
that only the ability user will retain
the arrow marks on their hands which is
more or less the only way to spot them
outside of general personality traits
alright so apologies for dumping you
with all ton of nin exposition but in
understanding of crawler 6 abilities
Argus 7 if we include bandit secret is
absolutely essential for this fight in
the meantime our other contender Hisoka
has just been waiting here patiently
like the wonderful chap he is and to
this conflict he brings nothing new to
the table it's pretty much just Bungie
gum for days but to be fair when you
wield the powers of both rubber and gum
what else would you really need well
we're probably about to find out so
immediately after the match commenced
Crowell invoked black voice by sticking
an antenna into the match judge and
manipulating him into attacking Hisoka
and something that I didn't mention in
black voices description is that the
user has a maximum of two antenna and
crawler strategically uses to convince
Hisoka that his original plan was to pin
him down with the judge and stick the
second antenna into him thus instantly
winning the conflict by virtue of being
able to control Hisoka himself this was
but an elaborate faints though allowing
crawler to land some physical blows
against Hisoka but the first phase of
this conflict would end with the judge
mysteriously exploding right in he
soaked his face a boss that he barely
managed to escape by using Bungie gum
but of course we all know what caused
that explosion and this was the first
instance of crawler demonstrating how he
can form some pretty crazy combinations
of his abilities as he marched the
judges body with both a Sun and a moon
symbol and then used black voice to
force the judge to trigger the explosion
himself essentially turning the judge
into a suicide bomber that could go off
a crawl assault discretion and while
this effort was unsuccessful in killing
Hisoka it did lead directly to the next
phase of cromoz plan in which he invoked
gallery fake to copy the body of the
judge and then used order stamp on the
new corpse to control it like a puppet
now you probably remember me saying that
due to the mindset of auto stamps
original user a call
did not qualify as a puppet however
crawlers circumvented that as apparently
a nen copy of a corpse fits into this
technical gray area in which can be
considered a puppet
Carola mostly did this as a simple
display of power essentially giving he
soaked or detailed lecture of his
abilities before jumping into full force
and using the mighty crowd of heavens
arena to his advantage by controlling
someone with black voice then using
convert hands to take on the appearance
of a random spectator and disappear into
a crowd of thoroughly terrified but
captivated individuals many of which was
going to escape potential death and in
this moment Hisoka began to realize the
predicament he was in Crowley's strategy
was incredibly problematic for him
because he had to be wary of getting too
close to him in case he had a second
antenna free for black boys however if
he Sokka went to keep his distance and
krohler was completely free to enact his
maddening combination of powers which
swiftly came to fruition actually a
squirrel used the combination of gallery
fake and all to stamp on mass to create
copy slash puppets of various audience
members and commanded them to attack
Hisoka meanwhile krola used this as a
distraction so that he could get in some
guaranteed hits on Hisoka
causing the magician to well let's just
say that he Sokka was thoroughly
enjoying himself at this point in the
battle and while he Sokka did creatively
use bungee gum to decapitate the puppets
with the head of a former puppet he was
also smart enough to realize that
defeating all of the puppets would allow
crawler to deactivate older stamp an
initiate gallery fake once again to
create a new army of puppets thus
keeping Hisoka in an infinite loop of
problems until he would potentially
eventually run out of stamina and be
overcome by Crow and his ami
and so he Sokka went about putting a
plan into motion for singling out
crawler also using the audience of
heavens arena to his advantage in
conjunction with Bungie gum to turn them
into something resembling human bullets
in order to pink Rojo down now well the
Hisoka was caught off guard again when
the crawler he had caught turned out to
be an audience member who had been made
to look like him with convert hands and
who was being controlled by black voice
Hisoka also came to further realize the
gravity of his situation in that the cop
is created by gallery fake when not
disappearing despite having been
decapitated
which only removed the effects of order
staff but the real problem was that all
of these copies were also marked by sun
and moon and with this he Sokka deduced
the crawlers ultimate attack would be a
rush of puppets all detonating upon him
in unison however even before that he
still could be outplayed by krola who
detonated a body that belonged to the
head that he soccer was swinging around
like some sort of bungee
mase but this action would blow off one
if he soaked his hands but more
importantly removing the bungee gum that
he had to fix to the ceiling of the
arena for an emergency escape so without
the use of his left hand he Sokka was
forced to use bungee gun primarily with
his feet but from here on out his fate
was sealed crowler had completely
mentally overcome him and eventually he
Sokka was forced to the ground assailed
by a group of puppets and killed in the
ensuing explosion his body was then
recovered by the Phantom troupe and it
was in pretty good condition actually
which was explained by the idea that the
mass of puppets around him cushions the
explosion somewhat and his actual cause
of death ended up being suffocation
rather than the actual detonation
however to say that this was Carla's
complete victory would be a lie because
he Sokka was about to do something
phenomenal just prior to his demise in
Heaven's arena
Hisoka used his vague knowledge of
post-mortem ninh to program a sequence
in which Bungie gun was able to restart
his heart and lungs off to death which
occurred in the presence of fandom
troupe member machi after waking up he
so could got a kick out of the fact that
his wild plan had actually worked and
used texture surprise to mold his aura
into the missing parts of his body which
I guess we could essentially call gum
prosthetics after making a full recovery
and seemingly more powerful than ever
Hisoka issued a warning Tamachi that
from now on he would cease his games and
fight and kill any phantom troupe member
on sight going on to make good on this
promise by immediately killing Shana and
caught Opie although he did spare machi
for now but the deaths of [ __ ] and
caught Opie are extremely relevant to
this discussion because black voice and
gallery fake abilities that were
previously Orange by the two of them
were absolutely integral to crawlers
ideal conditions to face ahsoka and with
the two of them dead assumedly chrono
has lost the use of those abilities oh I
guess I should say that it is currently
unknown if those abilities vanished from
his grasp or not because you know just
like the odor from eto City they may
have been subject to post-mortem nan
Fairy maybe but in any case as it stands
this fight is not over and currently the
entirety of the remaining phantom troupe
are on the hunt Figgy Sokka as part of
the succession war arc and that pretty
much does it for this breakdown of
Hisoka versus Corolla if you enjoyed
this video on the content this channel
produced in general and please do
consider donating to the new world revue
patreon because the support of all of
your amazing people is what continues to
make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel and Incred
and if you'd like to join the fun at
anytime then please do head over to my
discord server for a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on Hisoka vs. crow this
has been the new walter view and i'll
see you next time
[Music]